is one direction calling it quits et  sets the record straight nobody can drag  me down forget what you've heard harry  liam louis and Niall are not breaking up  source tells ET quote there's no truth  to this it remains a hiatus with the  intention of reuniting at some point as  the guys have said in all recent  interviews and that's exactly what the  band told us in November is one D deck  we're not breaking up were literally  taking time out to you know Sierra  friends and Sierra family and reflect on  what we've done over the last few years  and obviously you know it'd be naive was  to think that people are no readings  that in like 10 different ways but you  know we're just going to take a little  break